who's Stanton Friedman and what is the
Majestic 12.
Stanton was a friend of mine for over 20
years I I say that because he I think is
one of the last true researchers in this
field uh uh sadly passed away but where
I say one of the last I don't think a
lot of people understood the true
research that Stan did and he was an
amazing individual with a
um
an amazing background of the work that
he did with the US government he and I
became friends in the late 90s
and his main scope of research uh was a
group called Majestic 12 or mj-12 now he
and I slightly differed on our beliefs
of mj-12 but I was always impressed with
the level that Stanton would go to he
believed that the original what they
call Majestic 12 documents that came out
that they were genuine and essentially
it was a group of government people and
scientists that were essentially keeping
UFOs and the Extraterrestrial reality a
secret
and he had dove in on every single
character on those documents the people
that were mentioned the uh the claims
that were made even the typeset font on
the era the documents were allegedly
written uh the signatures that came
along with it I think Truman was one of
the signatures uh that they investigated
so when I say investigation he did every
ounce that you could think of when it
came to Majestic 12 and he determined
that they were real and I smile about it
because again he and I differed I I
didn't really feel that they were uh
legitimate I felt that they were based
on a hoax you had people that had come
out and said that they were a hoax but
Stanton was was true to the end that he
felt that they that they were real and
that always struck me because I had just
I'll make the story quick but I had an
opportunity when I lectured in DC to go
to the National Archives with Stanton
Friedman
and again he and I at this point were
friends for quite a few years so we were
talking about it and we said well let's
go together it's great what a you know
because this guy was a legend whether
you believed him or not it didn't matter
what believed his research I should say
or not God was a legend so we went and
to see the care that he took that that
isn't even conveyed in his books or even
his lectures but to see that firsthand
he was there pulling boxes mountains of
boxes you know that would come out in
carts and go through Page by Page by
page and I was on the other side uh
essentially doing the same thing just on
a different topic on that particular day
you were friends with him at this point
or you became friends from yeah no we
were we were friends and just decided to
go together and uh and it was an amazing
experience because you realize the
amount of research that he did and he
was one of those researchers which you
don't see nowadays that would pick up
the telephone and he would call people
you know nowadays we're like let's just
send an email maybe I can Linked In him
you know no Stanwood pick up the phone
you would figure out where people lived
and and call and uh and track down every
single lead and man I I respect that I
really do so it's always intrigued me
his determination on mj12 again he knew
that I differed a little bit on it but
friends to the end uh sadly though he
had passed away a couple years ago so
you're conflicted about mj-12 because
you admire Stan so much he believed in
it but you don't at the same time you
want to give a bit more Credence to what
he believes in because you feel like
he's such a great researcher so let me
keeps that door open a bit more that's
exactly it yeah and one last note that
I'll that I'll add to that always kind
of intrigued me was I have a huge
collection of FBI files and one angle
that Stanton had never really pursued uh
likely because it really didn't go to
the legitimacy of the mj-12 documents
was I had went after all of the FBI
files of every single mj-12 member and
every single mj-12 member had all or
part of their FBI file destroyed all a
coincidence maybe but there are millions
and millions of pages of FBI files that
have been released over the last quite a
few decades and yes document destruction
does happen but the odds to have you
know all of the mj-12 with either all or
some of their file destroyed I always
found intriguing one last note the FBI
also has a file on Majestic 12 on mj12
the documents that that we've been
talking about here and it essentially
has a copy of the documents but there's
handwritten bogus on it across
handwritten bogus sorry what does that
mean to ensure that nobody thought that
they were real top secret documents
meaning someone came about and wrote
with a marker the word bogus that's
correct yeah because the FBI determined
that they were bogus and so when you
have a document that says Top Secret at
top you don't want that misconstrued as
actually being top secret if it's a
bogus document sorry it's interrupt I
just want to know is the standard like
bogus sounds like a colloquial word
though so that's actually FBI lingo that
they use frequently I I mean I don't
know how official of a term it is in
this particular case that's what they
did off the top of my head I can't think
of any FBI file that I've gotten not
that I've searched for it but on any
document investigation that they've done
to figure out legitimacy
um and please don't read into that I
just I don't think off the top of my
head I I've ever gone after one
Majestic 12 exists the the file on that
because uh according to the FBI somebody
had found copies of these alleged top
secret documents in a hotel I think it
was and they sent them to the FBI and
the FBI began an investigation to see if
real top secret documents were laying on
a hotel floor or if they were a hoax now
they ultimately determined that they
were bogus and again I don't know if
that's an official term but I'll have to
look into that because now I'm morbidly
curious but the um
the root of why they believed they were
bogus was the FBI initiated con contact
with the Air Force office of special
investigations or afosi and afosi had
said to the FBI well we investigated
this given now uh what you have told us
and they are a hoax so then that went
back to the FBI FBI rights bogus and the
case is closed so I Revisited the file a
couple of years ago and started tracking
down the Air Force office of special
investigations files on what they did on
mj-12 because again the FBI stuff still
exists and they determined it was bogus
based on what afosi said so that's what
you do in foia you just kind of just
keep going for leads
afosi yeah Air Force office of special
investigations and so I filed the
request to them and found out just in
the last few months that everything
related to that was like destroyed so
all of it is gone none of us can find it
so I'm trying to look into the national
archives in hopes that maybe uh they had
archived it there but sadly this is
another puzzle piece in history that was
lost so some Skeptics point to that FBI
file so this is the bottom line Point
here some Skeptics will point to that
FBI file and say well look you know the
federal government looked into this and
the FBI deemed them bogus but the root
of that goes to a file we will never be
able to access there is no way to figure
out why they term them as bogus we just
have to believe it you know so that
doesn't prove anything other than
another frustrating puzzle piece is gone
for good that we'll never be able to
find
first to me is is this feel this UFO
field UAP field does it have more
destroyed documents and misinformation
than a generic field of the government
so for instance the NSA and what Edward
Snowden had leaked
I don't know if it's the case that prior
to Edward Snowden if you were to try and
investigate it you would run into as
many dead ends and lies and so on in
other words
is this just a generic problem of the
government or is there something special
about this topic this UAP topic
when it when it comes to destruction or
secrecy or both destruction
so with destruction I can tell you that
the CIA is the most problematic that
I've seen that I've that I know of that
has lost and or destroyed UFO documents
this goes back to material that cites
UFO physical evidence that was collected
by the CIA uh years after the closure of
Project Blue Book
the documents heavily redacted and
there's quite a few of them now I've got
got them all in different articles and
stuff uh but I what I do is I pull these
documents that were released a lot of a
lot of them in the late 1970s some in
the early 1980s heavily redacted you
just watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy